il a parcouru plus de 26 kilomètres pour
sensibiliser le grand public aux
questions de l'environnement
cet ancien ingénieur consacre
aujourd'hui son temps au vélo le message
qu au passé c'est que ce changement
climatique est une vraie une vraie
catastrophe pour l'humanité c'est aussi
une formidable opportunité pour changer
la société pour passer à un autre
changer de paradigme et puis une société
qui soit plus partageuse plus
bienveillante et finalement beaucoup
plus agréable à vivre
un engagement initié par sylvain ster
organisateurs de l'événement qui a prévu
ce tour à vélo mais aussi des
projections débats une démarche de
sensibilisation auprès du grand public
demandé par l'antenne nationale du
mouvement
il y avait du mouvement al rastan
nationale de faire un tour de france des
coopératives locales
dernièrement on avait hier on avait un
endroit avec plein d'alternative le
trial cool qui fonctionne donc c'était
ça l'objectif de cette journée c'est que
les cyclistes dû trouver des
alternatives à la découvre les toutes
les belles choses qui se passent à la
verrière le tour à vélo de l'énergie
citoyenne continue toute la semaine
prochaine étape le 22 septembre à
versailles